okay [ __ ] I just thought maybe
something will funny plus do this
[Music]
get back here you're not even hidden
have you got it I've been trying Trevor
I've been trying come on over here all
right I ain't gonna hit you I've been
trying I know I know I thought you said
you wasn't gonna hit me I thought you
said you were gonna find [ __ ] Michael
Townley there too Michael Townley living
in LS 183 and the other one you get
kindergarten I asked her teacher to put
him on the phone just to be safe she
threatened to call the cops ain't no
move esker Trevor shut up or I molest
you all right now is there anything else
i will prove a phone directory I kicked
buying a michael vick banta about the
right age married with two kids what's
his wife's name Amanda
Amanda yeah you're a genius you're more
on come on come here OOP don't you ever
not tell me things I want to know sorry
true run you little bastard get out here
we're going to Los Santos are we not you
me and wait what about me your CEO of
Trevor Phillips enterprises find out
some business or the we can make some
money and tidy my [ __ ] up let's go away
come on i'm driving and jerk me off if I
get bored I'm joking suck at y'all
yeah yeah we guys got for ice cream oh
so we're headed to locate jump in soon I
gotta make a stop Oh what's your top ice
cream road trip we're out shs in where
are your people out of labatto's you
kicked my cousin they're rolling he
spoke in with a girlfriend some place
called kikuchi beach go up what you stop
that was important wait not as important
as the man that's employed you mentor
you and said um feta means this last
year but it's important we gotta pay
this card so that guy being him in a
while Trevor all the more reason to drop
by okay ah I got mad me gag but where
are we stopping on the way cuz y'all get
tight a wet over here
mock pain
look at the morn maybe we're going ahead
i was thinkin me and you they are
welcome ere me look at you one
Oh
before I drop it again
oh [ __ ]
I the holy holy
we'll find out [ __ ]
I got you guys Bob you're not fit to
looking at making flag yeah I chuck them
those are my gift for a friend wait here
don't
alright
back
Oh sick you're the dude get a puppy [ __ ]
now we
it's easy
you you look fresh go go go
but your worms in the last hundred costs
don't want to die here
come on
[ __ ] i think a liability
right back
hey
get the hug
oh now that that's over let's get out of
town gross tricking stato
back up
banging agreement
[ __ ] his car now
you
Blake
the way up
when play
yeah Michael now my god like a dish you
all feel bad for you want to find you so
much even piss me off the guys that
children the federal government name is
me off if he did who cares now you're
starting to grasp the burden in question
who is this guy using my dead friends
tired ass movie quotes we might dead
friends alias and my good friends family
the house a must been paid for with my
good friend stash million Wow after real
mad rush i'll show you [ __ ] mine foot
I'm gonna stick my boy in your eyes come
on you're here huh haha I didn't mean
anything by Roxy Trevor lube up your
ihome [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] your tiny
minor get the [ __ ] out of here go get
yourself a great haha and put please
Trevor uh I thought you wanted to meet
cousin Floyd
[Music]
are we nearly there yet no way are we
nearly nearly there you keep this up
you're not gonna get there at all can
you tell me sorry no wait Kalia gay men
you know animal mineral or vegetable
I'll go first I'm nanotechnology what
you're what oh damn it I gave it away I
what I love you supposed to say what I
am I'll start again animal vegetable or
mineral bag how about this i'll tell you
a story if you promise never to speak
again I story of course you do miss
stories about a boy called trick tree on
Tricia he's just a boy named it doesn't
matter that's weird he was weird it was
the smartest toughest weirdest kid in
Canada well in the Canadian border
region of America okay this boy he had
all the talent charisma 10 Kyle that a
boy could have but he didn't know what
to do with it he should become a
baseball player
because he's not a [ __ ] sellout idiot
or hockey player he did for a while but
a joke accidentally had a six jammed up
with that that's it that giant brawl
awesome battles oh yeah [ __ ] a big again
go good you know Santos I guess it is I
always wanted to come here but you got
stuck in the desert big bill kaj best
part of the state
[Applause]
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] I wonder why I've
hasten
[Music]
so Michael this is we're dead men come
back to life the nearly 10 years but
you'll keep for another day or so an old
friend you mother [ __ ] [ __ ] white 3
for you we're naked [ __ ] dead you
were my best friend well guess who's
coming to [ __ ] on your doorstep you [ __ ]
flying around here what are you doing
los santos the city of [ __ ] head where
else would he be Molly coloring is qg
beach will you tell me a story about
that boy Trisha ah yeah yeah where were
we right right right right so this kid
he could fly plane so he signed up for
the airport to fly all day long and bomb
villages and maybe just maybe drop the
nuke and it was all going well until one
day just before he got his wings and
evil witch in charge of psychological
evaluations told him he was unstable
yeah and grounded him for life that's
terrible you one send him to it deep his
dope despair I just then just go through
the hit rock bottom he met a bat silver
tongue troll under a bridge that goal of
Gautreau's name what miss Michelle a
lady troll yeah hit him like one no no
well he was a boy Michelle is a funny
name for a boy oh this was a funny boy
he said under his bridge robbing anyone
who backed him by sometimes he going to
town and rob his shop and in such and he
persuaded our hero that maybe he should
rob people do you know what little
trisha is wrong people
and little Trisha was good
I can live happily ever after a while
until the troll met another troll in a
strip club the next fell in lust and he
bought her a pair of fake troll test
even bigger than his real troll test so
she could make more money stripping
maybe a little on the side without call
work but you didn't hear that from me oh
oh we're here fluid test I sing it on
i-5 map I'll GG direction
yo turn here
yeah good to play okay kitty eagerly
visit
oh yeah
cousin Floyd come up here Trevor hung
it's me why Oh me wait your cousin who
was it [ __ ] come to visit you you're
rude but now get up off the floor and
fix me a [ __ ] drink oh you wait I
heard you was up smoking mask employer
no not somewhere here he's gonna smoke
meth here give me a [ __ ] lighter you
can't smoke here okay this is my
girlfriend's place she's had a business
conference you can't smoke here and you
can't stay here how's it going busy it's
been a while yeah I ain't sayin you said
she was called Neverland said a guy was
never crude you gotta go both of you my
girlfriend she kill me if she knew I
have guests that's not much of a
girlfriend if you don't like your family
now would you get me a [ __ ] drink I'm
not gonna ask you again oh yes wait I
don't know booze and you go out and
[ __ ] get me something you go to AA
jate that
that's kind of go thank you thank you